Merry Christmas this December 25th we
celebrate the birth of Jesus Christ but
was Jesus really born on this day well a
lot of biblical Scholars don't think so
you see in the Gospel of Luke it
describes Shepherds grazing their flocks
this would only have been done in the
spring so by this account Jesus was
probably born in the spring okay so why
do we celebrate in December well poke
Julius the first declared it to be so in
the year 350. why well there are a few
theories the most famous one is that he
set it up to be in line with the Roman
Festival of saturnalia this might be
true but saturnalia was actually held in
mid-December not December 25th a more
likely explanation is that it was placed
to correspond to the winter solstice the
shortest day and longest night of the
year this of course has a lot of
theological symbolism the truth is
though that December 25th is as good a
day as any to celebrate Christmas
because we just don't know and probably
never will know exactly when Jesus was
born so